iraqi and the sports memorabilia market
it's on fire right now and this weekend
there's a new and different collectors
event the mint collective here to tell
us more is blake allrich the vp of
business operations for events at img
welcome to the show how is this event
different than other collectors events
so i think um previously historically
it's been more of a trade show or
marketplace type format here together
we're bringing executives from brands
we're bringing the brands themselves
we're bringing
you know celebrities and we're going to
have a marketplace associated with that
but the plan is to talk about
where this sports boom is going where
these where these collectibles can be as
alternative assets and there's a lot of
money and a lot of value in these things
now and so we want to educate everyone
on how to take it to the next level and
they are assets you hear about some of
these things that are selling online for
top dollar what are some of the big
names they're going to be there this
weekend so we're really excited one of
our featured speakers will be peyton
manning
the founder of omaha productions we'll
have uh ezra levine the founder of
collectible
um jerry rice
nice of course 49ers raiders
and there will be there will be a host
of other people that will be there from
you know executives from all the major
brands panini tops draftkings fanatics
we're really excited i love going to
these events one walking around looking
at stuff you can buy but also kind of
just seeing some of the crazy stuff will
you guys have stuff on display out there
this weekend there'll be a tremendous
amount on display so people will be able
to buy sell and trade in the marketplace
and they'll be able to see
see the rare things as well you know you
might find you know a few
rare jesse owens gold medals potentially
have never been seen
you might find some jackie robinson
memorabilia maybe you'll even see our
friend babe ruth there you know so
there'll be a lot of great things there
where where is the market going right
now someone wants to get into this
should they be buying hockey cards
baseball cards where's the market going
five ten years from now it's a great
question um
so all of these are you know being
looked at as alternative assets right
and and all of the sports cards are are
there they're
they're um exciting for a lot of the
sports patrons out there etc but don't
be surprised if you see
non-sports cards and cultural cards
maybe hollywood get a little bit more
involved and things of that nature so
there's lots of different ways it can go
beyond just sports so how can someone
watching get they want to get into the
game they see cards selling for big
money they see knee pads from the
ultimate warrior selling for top dollar
maybe 50 bucks how can someone get into
the game do you buy a pack of cards and
hopefully you have a hot rookie that's
gonna be worth some money down the road
how do you get into the game
there's a couple different ways you can
do it so these are all investment
strategies right so so they call that
prospecting is looking for the rookie
that's going to be the next superstar
right or you can buy into a veteran and
someone who might actually be more of a
stable environment so like you could go
both ways and again to round out a
portfolio you can have both right so
that's what a lot of people will do from
from those perspectives and this weekend
this is big business and you guys will
be discussing you'll have everything on
display you can buy stuff but also the
business side of it blake we appreciate
it the website people want to buy
tickets what's the website
dubmincollective.com awesome thank you
blake we'll send it over to you